let's say we have the indefinite
integral of the square root of 6x minus
x squared minus 5 and obviously this is
not some simple integral I don't have
just you know this expression and then
it's derivative lying around so u
substitution won't work and so you can
guess from just the title of this video
that we're gonna have to do something
fancier and we'll probably have to do
some type of trig substitution but this
immediately doesn't look kind of
amenable to trig substitution I like to
do trig substitution when I see kind of
a 1 minus x squared under a radical sign
or maybe an x squared minus 1 under a
radical sign or maybe a x squared plus 1
these are the type of things that get my
brain thinking in terms of trig
substitution but that doesn't quite look
like that just yet I have a radical sign
I have some x squared but it doesn't
look like in this form so let's see if
we can get it to being in this form so
let me delete these guys right there
real fast so the the interest let's see
if we can write maybe complete the
square down here so let's see if this is
equal to let me rewrite this and if this
completing the square doesn't look
familiar to you have a whole bunch of
videos on that let me rewrite this as
equal to minus 5 - I need more space up
here minus 5 minus x squared now there's
a plus 6 X but I have a minus out here
so minus 6 X right a minus and a minus
will become this plus 6 X and then I
want to make this into a perfect square
so what number when I add to itself will
be minus 6
well it's minus 3 and minus 3 squared so
you take half of this number you get
minus 3 and then you square it and so
you put a 9 there now I can't just
arbitrarily add 9 so actually I didn't
add a 9 here what did i do i subtracted
a 9 because I threw a 9 there but it's
really a minus 9 because of this minus
sign out there so in order to make this
neutral to my 9 that I just threw in
there this is a minus 9 I have to add a
9 so let me add a 9 so plus 9 right
there if this doesn't make complete
sense what I just did and obviously have
the DX right there multiply this out
multiply this you get minus x squared
plus 6x which are these two terms right
there minus 9 and then
this +9 and these two will cancel out
and you'll just get exactly back to what
we had before because I want you to
realize I didn't change the equation and
this is a minus 9 because of this so I
added a 9 so I really added zero to it
but what this does is it gets it into a
form that I like obviously this right
here just becomes a 4 and then this term
right here becomes what that is X minus
3 squared X minus 3 squared so my
indefinite integral now becomes the
integral I'm just doing a little bit of
algebra the integral of the square root
of 4 minus 4 minus X minus 3 squared X
minus 3 squared DX now this is starting
to look at like a form that I like but I
like to have a 1 here so let's factor a
4 out so this is equal to I'll switch
colors
that's equal to the integral of the
radical and we'll have the 4 times 1
minus X minus 3 squared over 4 I just
took a 4 out of both of these terms if I
multiply this out I'll just get back to
that right there DX and now this is
trying to look like a form that I like
let me simplify it even more so this is
equal to the integral if I take the
square 4 out it becomes 2 times the
square root of 1 minus and I can rewrite
this as X minus 3 let me write it this
way 1 minus X minus 3 over 2 squared DX
and where did I get that to from well if
I just square both of this I get X minus
3 squared over 2 squared which is X
minus 3 over 4 so I've just just I have
done no calculus so far I just
algebraically rewrote this indefinite
integral as this indefinite integral
they are equivalent but this all of a
sudden looks like a form that I
recognize I showed you in the last video
that cosine squared of theta is just
equal to 1 minus sine squared of theta
you could actually do it the other way
you can do sine squared is equal to 1
minus cosine squared no difference but
they both will work out but this this
looks an awful lot like this
in fact it look exactly like this if I
say that that is equal to sine squared
of theta so let me make that
substitution let me write let me write
that X minus three X minus three over
two squared is equal to is equal to sine
squared of theta now if we take the
square root of both sides of that
equation I get X minus three over two is
equal to sine of theta now where
eventually you know where this is going
to go we're eventually gonna have to
substitute back for for theta so let's
solve for theta in terms of X so theta
in terms of X we could just say just
take the arc sine of both sides of this
you get theta is equal to write the arc
sine of the sine is just theta theta is
equal to the arc sine of X minus three
over two
fair enough now to actually do the
substitution though we're going to have
to order figure out what DX is we're
going to solve for x in front terms of
theta so let me do that so we get if we
multiply both sides equation by 2 we get
X minus 3x minus three is equal to two
times the sine of theta or that X is
equal to two sine of theta plus three if
we take the derivative of both sides
with respect to theta we get DX D theta
is equal to two cosine of theta
derivative this is just zero or we can
multiply both sides by D theta and we
get DX is equal to two cosine of theta D
theta and we're ready to substitute back
into our original indefinite integral so
this thing will now be re-written as the
integral of two times the radical and we
get some space of one - I'm replacing
this with sine squared of theta sine
squared of theta and then all of that
times DX well you just said that DX is
equal to this right here so DX is equal
to
to cosine of theta d-theta
now what does this simplify to this
action right here this is just cosine
squared of theta and we're going to take
the square root of cosine squared of
theta so this is the square root of
cosine squared of theta this whole term
right here right that becomes the square
root of cosine squared of theta which is
this the same thing as cosine of theta
so our integral becomes so our integral
is equal to two times the square root of
cosine squared of theta so that's just
two times cosine of theta times two
times cosine of theta times two times
cosine of theta that's that one right
there
this is this and all of this radical
sign that's this right there it just
this one minus sine squared was cosine
squared take the radical you get cosine
squared and then everything times D
theta D theta now this is obviously this
is equal to four times cosine squared of
theta D theta which by itself is still
not an easy integral to solve I don't
know I you know I it's I can't do u
substitution or anything like that there
so what do we do well we resort to our
good old our good old trig identities
now I don't know if you have this one
memorized although it tends to be in the
inside cover of most calculus books or
inside cover over most trig books but
cosine squared of theta cosine squared
of theta can be re-written as one half
times one plus cosine of two theta and
I've proven this in multiple videos so
let's just make this substitution let me
just replace this thing with that thing
so this integral will become it becomes
it equals four times cosine squared of
theta but cosine squared of theta is
this four times one half times one plus
cosine of two theta D theta
d-theta now this looks easier to to deal
with so what is this 4 times 1/2 that's
2 so my integral my integral becomes the
integral of 2 times 1 so it's 2 plus 2
times 2 cosine of 2 theta all of that D
theta
now this antiderivative is pretty
straightforward what is this right here
this is this is the derivative with
respect to theta of cosine of sorry of
sine of 2 theta right this whole thing
what's the derivative of sine of 2 theta
take the derivative of the inside that's
2 times the derivative of the outside
cosine of 2 theta and this of course is
the derivative of 2 theta so this is
equal to the antiderivative of 2 with
respect to theta is just 2 theta plus
the antiderivative of this which is just
sine of 2 theta sine of 2 theta sine of
2 theta and then we have a plus C and of
course we can't forget that we defined
theta we you know our original
antiderivative was in terms of X so we
can't just leave it in terms of theta
we're gonna have to do a back
substitution so let's just remember
theta was equal to arc sine of X minus 3
over 2 let me write that on the side
here theta is equal to arc sine of X
minus 3 over 2 now if I immediately
substitute this data straight into this
I'm going to get a sine of 2 times arc
sine of X minus 3 over 2 which would be
correct and I would have a 2 times arc
sine of X minus 3 over 2 and that would
all be fine and we would be done but
that's not satisfying it's not a nice
clean answer so let's see if we can if
we can simplify this so it's only in
terms of sine of theta because you take
the sine of the arc sine then you're
definitely then it just simplifies to X
minus 3 over 2 let me let me make that
clear if I take so if I can write all of
this in terms of sines of theta because
the sine of theta let me write that the
sine of theta
is equal to the sign of the arc sine
sine of the arc sine of X minus three
over two which is just equal to X minus
three over two so if I can write this in
terms of sines of theta then I can just
make this substitution sine of theta
equals that and everything simplifies a
good bit so let's see if we can do that
well you may or may not know the the
other identity and I've proven this as
well that sine of two theta sine of two
theta that's the same thing as sine of
theta times sine of theta or the sine of
theta plus theta that's equal to sine of
theta plus theta same thing which is
equal to sine of theta cosine of theta
plus the other Thetas get swapped around
sine of theta plus cosine of theta which
is equal to this is just the same thing
written twice to sine of theta cosine of
theta some people have this memorized
ahead of time and if you're going to
take an exam on trig substitution
doesn't hurt to have this memorized
ahead of time but let's rewrite this
like this so our indefinite integral in
terms of theta or our antiderivative
became 2 theta plus instead of sine of
two theta we could write 2 sine of theta
cosine of theta and then of course we
have a plus C now I want to write
everything in terms of sines of theta
but I have a cosine of theta there so
what can we do well we know we know that
cosine squared of theta is equal to one
minus sine squared of theta or that
cosine of theta is equal to the square
root of one minus sine squared of theta
which seems like we're adding complexity
to it but the neat thing is it's in
terms of sine of theta so let's do that
let's make the substitution so our
antiderivative this is the same thing as
two theta plus 2 sine of theta times
cosine of theta which is equal to this
times the square root of 1 minus sine
squared of theta and then all that plus
C and now we're at the home stretch this
problem was probably harder than you
thought
going to be we know that sine theta is
equal to X minus 3 over 2 so let's make
that reverse substitution so we have 2
times theta this first term is just 2
times theta right there so that's 2
times we know what theta is equals we
can't escape the arcsine if you just
have a theta we have to say that theta
is equal to arc sine arc sine of X minus
3 over 2 and then we have plus let me
switch colors plus 2 sine of theta
well that's plus 2 times sine of theta
is X minus 3 over 2 so 2 times X minus 3
over 2 and then all of that times the
square root the square root of 1 minus
sine of theta squared what's sine of
theta it's X minus 3 over 2 squared and
of course we have a plus C and let's see
if we can simplify this even more now
that we're already at the homestretch so
this is equal to 2 arc sine of X minus 3
over 2 plus these two terms that this 2
and this 2 cancel out plus X minus 3
times the square root of what happens if
we multiply everything here by let's see
if we let's see if we take a so this is
equal to 1 minus X minus 3 over 4 X
minus 3 squared over 4 this
simplification I should write that in
quotes is taking me longer than I
thought but let's see if we can simplify
this even more if we multiply let me
just focus on this term right here if we
multiply the outside if or let's say
let's let's multiply and divide this by
2 so I'll write this as so let's just
multiply this times 2 over 2 2 over 2
and you might say Sal why are you doing
that because I can rewrite this let me
write my whole thing here so I have to
arc sine
of X minus 3 over 2 and then I have I
can take this denominator 2 right here
so I say plus X minus 3 over 2 that's
that too is that 2 right there and then
I could write this 2 right here as the
square root of 4 times the square root
of 4 times the square root of all of
this 1 minus X minus 3 squared over 4
and I think you see where I'm going I'm
kind of reversing everything that I did
at the beginning of this problem and
maybe I'm getting a little fixated on
making this as simple as possible but
I'm so close so let me finish so I get 2
times the arc sine of X minus 3 over 2
which I am tired of writing plus X minus
3 over 2 and then if we bring this 4 in
write the square root of 4 times the
square root of that is equal to the
square root of 4 times these things so
it's 4 minus X minus 3 squared all of
that plus C and we're at the home
stretch
this is equal to 2 times the arc sine of
X minus 3 over 2 plus X minus 3 over 2
times the radical of 4 minus let's
expand this x squared minus 6x plus 9
and then this expression right here
simplifies to this simplifies to minus
minus it's 6 X 6x minus x squared and
then you have a 4 minus 9 minus 5 which
was our original antiderivative which is
our original antiderivative so finally
we're at the very end we get the
antiderivative is to arc sine of X minus
3 over 2 plus X minus 3 over 2 times let
me make this times the radical of 6x
minus x squared minus 5 that right there
is the antiderivative of what this thing
that we had at the very top of my little
chalkboard which is right there
so that is equal to the antiderivative
of the square root of 6x minus x squared
minus 5 DX and I can imagine that you're
probably as tired as I am my hand
actually hurts but hopefully you find
that to be vaguely satisfying sometimes
I get complaints that I only do easy
problems well this was quite a hairy and
not so easy problem